[Applause]
first of all how did you find your
voice when you were starting your show
because i know you went in
and pitched a show but you
you really took the bull by the horns
you
i talk about how this is a mood board of
a show and
every bit of research i do just shows
how much you knew yourself and the show
you wanted to make
which i love well that's very kind of
you to say
i mean we i think what we knew
is that we didn't have a luxury of time
um you know i hadn't i hadn't been on a
american talk show um until i got the
job
of being a sort of late night talk show
host i'd never been on one of those
shows i'd never
really been on american tv i'd never
done any of those things so for quite a
long time i found myself saying
no one knows who i am i have never been
on saturday night live i'm not
on the daily show no one knows who i am
or what i can do this is impossible and
then what you do
is you go well anything that we're
looking at now as a negative
can be a positive and suddenly if you
take the very same phrase and go
no one knows who i am no one knows what
i can do here if you go well wait
no one knows who i am and nobody knows
what i can do here
and that actually then becomes
incredibly exciting are you the type of
person that has a fear of getting fired
from a job you love oh constantly
i even the first when we moved here my
wife and i
we had two kids at that point and
i wouldn't allow us to buy furniture
we rented all of our furniture because i
said to
my wife julia i said i'm going to get
fired
this won't work and as soon as we get
fired
we'll just want to get back to london so
we don't want to be lumbered with a
couch and i did that for two years
and then eventually my wife was like
please
can we buy some furniture and i was like
okay i think we're safe to buy furniture
now
but yeah but that's been every day of my
adult life really i thought i'm gonna
get fired at some point
it's just refreshing to hear that you
felt that way because
i joke about it all the time but i'm not
really joking i'm like no i'm getting
fired and it's just
like a comedic mechanism of
being afraid that i'm gonna lose this at
any second
but then i think that's quite a healthy
point of view because i think
outside of even work just in life if you
can
constantly try to google earth yourself
realize where you are realize what
you're doing
fundamentally hang on to the very things
that are important
so counting those blessings and checking
your privileges and all those things i
think are
a really useful and necessary thing to
do especially if you're doing the job
that you're doing the job that i do at
the moment which is where you have to
come out every day and go
well here i am and this is how i feel
and there's a responsibility to that but
the more free you are to just go
ah like i actually think that's one of
the few positives you could take from
coronavirus is if you and i had talked a
year ago i'd say how are you doing and
you go i'm great
everything's great and i go same
everything's fantastic
and actually there's been an amazing
thing that's happened over this last six
seven months where i'll talk to friends
of mine at home
and i'll go how are you doing and
they'll go do you know what i'm
struggling to be honest
i'm struggling and you go oh that's a
great thing to be able to say
ah this is this is how i feel and that's
a really lovely thing that i hope we
don't lose when we're the other side of
this
i couldn't agree more
[Music]
you